What's your favorite movie memory?
What I mean is what's your fondest
memory while watching a movie?
The question came to me this morning
when I was watching the episode of Louis
Ck is horace and Pete,
it's a TV show that he produced on his
website and it's great.
There's this interesting segment where
an old man enters their bar.
I'm going to let the whole scene play
out.
I really encourage you to get the first
episode.
If you enjoy this.
My mother would send me here for a Pail
of beer for my dad.
We used to sell beer pills out the bank.
Yeah.
And I,
I,
I came here to get my first beer and I
met my wife here.
She was sitting
in that stool.
Yeah.
And we were.
We were married for
years and
I was happy and then I heard that she
was sleeping with my best friend and so
I showed up here one night and she was
sitting in that stool again with my best
friend kissing her and I just shot them
both dead.
Yeah,
that was back in 1961.
I just got to go to jail today.
That guy really there
you want a beer?
So here's my question.
Was that segment tragic or funny?
I think the first instinct is to find it
morbid.
Certainly a man murdering his wife and
spending his life in prison is tragic,
but the way it's presented is also
comedic.
It's a rollercoaster of events.
I was choking on my morning Bagel from
laughter at how his story got absurdly
worse and worse.
I'm a big believer that the funniest
moments are the ones that are also the
saddest.
I watched daddy's home the other day and
it's fine.
It had some good labs,
but with comedies like daddy's home,
there's always something missing and
that brings me to my point.
The funniest movies are also the saddest
movies.
It's the tragicomedy hear me out on this
one.
I'd venture to say that the vast
majority of comedy these days contains
characters who served no other purpose
but to make us laugh.
Stuff like bridesmaids and spaceballs
and they're great.
Those are classics and I think Mel
Brooks is a genius,
but there's something inherently shallow
about the comedy.
All we got was laughter,
but with this moment from horace and
Pete,
there's such a huge spectrum of emotion.
It goes from a laugh,
the fact that he met his wife there and
caught her cheating there to a very sad
moment,
a homicide to a final resolution.
Pete offering him a drink.
That rollercoaster is just well better.
It means more that way.
It really lingers with me afterwards
when I experience multiple emotions in
one moment,
not just laughter and it's different
from dark comedy.
Dark comedy is when you make comedy out
of something that's supposed to be
taboo,
but tragic comedy is when you let the
sad moments be genuinely sad,
and the funny moments as a result are
more genuinely funny.
This scene brought me back to my
favorite memory of watching a movie.
I was watching little Miss Sunshine with
my mom,
Dad and sister,
and this scene came up.
Slight spoilers ahead in this scene,
dwayne finds out he can't fulfill his
dream of becoming a
pilot.
You cannot fly jets
rewatching it.
It's certainly a tragic scene,
right?
But here we see another essential moment
of tragic comedy.
The funniest moments are also the
saddest moments.
As soon as he found out he was
colorblind,
I started getting emotional,
but then frank has his perfect.
Thanks.
Okay.
Got An emergency
and at this point my mom busts out
laughing and all of a sudden I do too.
Uncontrollable laughter and my sister
and dad think we're crazy.
So is the scene funny?
Well,
no,
it's tragic,
but at the same time,
yes it is fight.
The lows are low,
but the highs are high.
Steve Carell is a master of comedy
because he earns his last by also having
his sad side
and that's when I decided to check out
early.
Yes,
yes,
and I failed at that as well.
He has that perfect balance throughout
the movie.
I've noticed his best movies put him as
a pathetic character while the movies
where he's always goofy,
don't have that spark any ads.
His talent to my favorite movie memory,
every character choice makes this seem
perfect.
The Way Dwayne maniacally punches the
side of the car,
the car horn honking randomly.
The fact that Richard Texas watching
argues that they don't have time to pull
over Dwayne's reaction is priceless.
It's going to be good
at this point.
I'm in tears,
sad tears,
but I'm also laughing hysterically.
The climax of the scene is pretty much
perfect.
My Dad and sister were looking at my mom
and me dumbfounded.
How could we be so cruel and
insensitive?
Can't they see?
This is tragic.
No,
it's not tragic.
It's better than tragic.
It's tragic comedy because last time I
checked,
life is tragic and funny,
but 99 percent of movies are either one
or the other and the ones that you both
are the diamonds in the rough.
Once you noticed this type of movement,
you can't help but appreciate it that
much more.
So that became my favorite movie memory,
laughing and crying at the same time
with my mom.
What a treat those movies that genuinely
capture the human experience.
Sometimes it's tragic.
Sometimes it's comedy,
right?
Thanks.